[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ولد القارئ والحافظ والامام ماي ايجون او
نور الاسلام ابراهيم لاسره مسلمه في
مقاطعه خنانه الصينيه حيث تعد نحو 110
ملايين نسمه كان والده اماما ومدرسا في
مدرسه اسلاميه وامه تتولى تدريس والتوجيه
النساء المسلمات عاش في اجواء اسلاميه
ودرس العلوم الشرعيه متنقنا لالاف
الكيلومترات بحثا عن العلم والمعرفه قبل
التحاقه بجامعه بيكين طالبا في قسم اللغات
وتحديدا اللغه العربيه
انا اسمي بالعربي نور الاسلام ابراهيم مي
مي اسماعيلتي بالصيني اسم الصيني ماي
ايجون معناه
نور الاسلام نور اسلام
ايجو نور الاسلام ماي هذه اسم عائلتي
طبعا الحمد لله انا ولدت في اسره مسلمه
اصليه والدي كان امام مسجد رحمه الله عليه
وامام معروف في منطقتنا
نحن من وسط الصين ولايه خنان مقاومه
فيها اكثر من 110 مليون نسمه
وكذلك والدتي رحمه الله عليها هي امامه
للمسجد للنساء لانه في الصين كلها فقط في
ولايتنا هناك مسجد للنساء فقط مستقله مثل
مسجد للرجال
والحمد لله يعني بعدما ولدت انا عشت في جو
اسلامي
يعني تعاليم الديني من الوارد
ولما كنا صغار حقيقه نحن تعلمنا حروف
او نسمون النطق اللغه العربيه
لكن ليس نطق السليمه يعني باللهجه الصينيه
تعلمنا اللغه العربيه
الف وباء جيم حتى العرب يسمحوا ممكن لا
يفهم
ثم الحمد لله
التحقنا بالمدارس
الحكوميه الين تخرجنا ثم الوالد
كان جلس معي
[موسيقى]
ونصحني قال يعني انا
افضل ان يعني تكمل دراستك في علوم الشرعيه
يعني تبدا
تعمق في
الدراسه او تعلم القران الكريم والتلاوتها
وعلوم الشرعيه لانه هو يرى ان في الصين
يحتاج يعني
علماء الراسخون يعني في العلم
حتى يقوم يعني دعوه
للمسلمين او غير المسلمين حتى يعني يعتوا
الناس لان نحن في الصين اقليات
يعتوا الناس صوره صحيحه للاسلام يعني كثير
من الناس يعني اخطاوا او لم يفهم الاسلام
بصوره صحيحه
فالحمد لله انا منذ تقريبا عمري كان 18
بدات ادرس علوم الشرعيه والحمد لله لانه
من صغري كنت احب التجويد تلاوه القران
فانا اذكر كان ما شال من حسن حظي كنت عندي
خيارين كلها طبعا
ليس في بلدي بعيد مكان ممكن 3000 متر كيلو
متر عن بيتي مكان الف متر لكن اخترت هذا
ايماني قراءته
جميل كان في الصين ما شاء الله معروف في
التلاوه القران والحمد لله
ذهبت
ودرست عنده كان هذا بدايه
تعلمي
في تجويد
القران الكريم ما كان عندنا قليل جدا كان
ذلك الوقت
تسعينات بدايه التسعينات قليل جدا في
الصين يعني هناك تجويد ما كل تلاوه تقليدي
نحن سنون التقليدي
ثم انا اذكر جيد جيد كان اول كاسيت انا
اسمعها
الشيخ عبد الباسط رحمه الله عليه كان اظن
في عام 90 تسعه وثمانين سبحان الله يعني
تاثرت بتلاوته
وتعجبته قلت سبحانك كيف في الدنيا في هذا
السود انا اذكر جيد هو يقرا الفاتحه مع
سوره ضحى كانه نفس واحد قلت يا الله كيف
هذه صوت ليس من بني هذه الصوت ما شاء الله
ممكن من الجنه
فمن ذلك الوقت دخل الحب في القران بدات
يعني
اقلد من احب من ذلك الوقت
يعني ثم انا اذكر سبحان الله درست
في عندنا معهد علوم الشرعيه سنوات ثم
ذهبت الى بكين درست في جامعه بكين وفي
معهد اللغات كان كاللغه لان عندنا
في
التعليم المعهد غير تعليم مثلا الجامعات
نحن كنا
نتعلم التلاوه القران نحو صرف والنحو بلاغ
لكن لا لا نفهم اذا سمعنا اللغه العربيه
لا نفهم ولا نتكلم ولكن نستطيع نقرا
ونستطيع ان نفهم نترجمها ثم
ذهبت الى جامع
لاتعلم كاللغه
سماعه
والكلام
التحدث الى الحمد لله كان جاءني فرصه انا
اذكر عام
فجاءني فرصه
ذهبت الى السودان كنت درست في السودان
جامعه افريقيا العلميه
ثم سبحان الله كان امامي خيارات وانا اذكر
جيدا كنت
اعطوني خيارات جامع عمر ام درمان
الاسلاميه جامع القران الكريم جامع
افريقيا العالميه
فكذلك طبعا الحمد لله اخترت الجامعه
افريقيا العالميه وفي جامعه
جاءني ممكن
يعني
فرصه اخرى
لاعمق في تعلم القران الكريم اللي انا
اسمع
تلاوه غير تلاوه نحن درسنا في الصيد يعني
نحن طبعا في الصين كلها حفصه عن عاصم ثم
هناك سمعته في تلاوه غير تلاوتنا
في بدايه الامر استغربت ثم سبحان الله
عرفت ان هناك قراءات
سبعه وعشره مختلفه بعدين سمعت ان كان ما
شاء الله المتقنين في
التلاوه بدا
يحدثني لماذا هذه
القراءات ولماذا هذه الاختلافات هل هي
اختلافك كان اختلاف
المذاهب الفقهيه صنبا لما فهمت ان هذه كل
هذه القراءات
يعني اصله من النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ثم
جاء من وحي من جبريل ومن الله يعني كل هذه
القراءات العشره المتواتره من الله بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم
ان هذا القران
هي اقوم
ويبشر المؤمنين
الذين
يعملون
الصالحات
ان لهم
اجرا كبيرا
وان الذين لا يؤمنون
بالاخره
اعتدنا لهم
عذابا
اليما ويدعو
الانسان بالشر
[موسيقى]
بالخ
ير وكان
الانسان
عجولا
وجعلنا الليل
والنهايتين فمحو
نايه الليل وجعل
نا ايه
النهار مبصرا
لتبتغوا فضلا
من ربكم
ولتعلموا
ولتعلموا عدد السنين والح
ساب
وكل شيء
فصلناه تفصيلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لم تتوقف مسيره نور الاسلام عند حفظ
القران والحديث والعلوم الشرعيه بل حرص
على تعلم اللغه العربيه من اهلها فامضى
سنوات في السودان وعدد من الدول العربيه
ساعيا لاتقان اللغه التي يعتبرها بوابه
العبور الى فهم القران وتدبره ورغم ازدهار
اعماله التجاريه التي برع فيها قررت تفرغ
لتعليم الصينيين اصول الدين الاسلامي
فاستقر في احدى ضواحي العاصمه الماليزيه
كوالالمبور لامامه مسجد تامه الجاليه
الصينيه المسلمه وتلتقي فيه لتداول شؤونها
وتعلم القران الكريم
انا اذكر جيد
في عام 2018
ذهبت الى العمره
وكانت اخر عمره لي من تلك اللحظه الى الان
وفي اثناء العمره
كنت افكر
دائما على وصيه الوالد رحمه الله عليه هو
كان امام معروف جدا في الصين وله تلاميذ
من
انحاء الصين
لكن كان احدى امنيته قال لي يا ولدي لا
اريد ان اكون لا اريدك ان تكون تاجرا
مهندسا مع ان هذه الوظائف تفيد للمجتمع
ولكن اريدك ان تكون اماما داعيا عالما
تخدم لدينك
تنشر دينك بصوره صحيحه الناس لا يفهمون لا
يعرفون
الاسلام بصوره صحيحه حتى ابناء المسلمين
وهذه مهمتك
كلنا
يعني سنرجع الى الله
فانا اذكر في في العمر افكر افكر ماذا
قدمت
لنفسي ولديني
[موسيقى]
وللمسلمين
يعني سبحان الله
في اثناء العمره
لا ادري جاءني يعني
عزيمه وهمه
ولا خلاص انا لازم يعني ارجع
وان شاء الله يعني
اريد اتبع ما وصاني الوارد
فسبحان الله في تلك اللحظه وانا اذكر جيد
واطوف طواف
وانا ادعو يعني ادعو الله سبحانه ان
يرزقني وان يجعلني اماما يعني متقيا
ويجعلني عالما ربانيا
وسبحان الله بعد العمره حدث لشيء يعني
غريب قليلا تقريبا بعد خرجت من مكه الى
جده
جاءني فرصه لانه لاحسن
هناك فرصه لاكمل الدراسه الدكتوره في جامع
اسلاميه ماليزيه
فسبحان الله ومن تلك اللحظه كلمت اخواني
قلت لهم خلاص انا الان لا اريد اي شيء
يعني سوف اتوقف كل اعمالي
واستمر في دراسه وفي دعوه
لا يصدقون حتى لا اصدق انا نفسي لا اصدق
كثيرا من الاخوه لا يصدقون ذلك لكن الحمد
لله هذا هذا قراري
واحسب ان هذه ان شاء الله
عون من الله وكذلك ان شاء الله هذا يعني
من
حسنات الوالد
ثم قررت ان ان شاء الله
اكون
داعيه الى الله ولكن كنت اقول انا لست
عالما ولازم اكمل او استمر في دراسه يعني
حتى انا نفسي اعرف ما هو ديني ما هو
عقيدتي ما هو الاسلام ما هو
القران وسنه فالحمد لله
بعد ما جئت الى ماليزيا
بعد الاخوه يسالونني ما هو شعورك انا اقول
له
عندي بعد
هم
ولكن انا قلت لهم بعد ما جئت هنا انا اشعر
نفسي في جنه والحمد لله جنه الدنيا يعني
اتقر وحاول ان اتقرب الى الله وادرس واقرا
القران واحفظ واستمر حتى في دراسه
[موسيقى]
الاحاديث لان التخصصي الان فقه واصول
الفقه في الفقه
واسع يعني ابذل جهد في طلبه العلم في طلب
العلم
وخاصه خاصه انا اشعر يعني
خلال هذه ثلاثه سنوات بعد ما جئت الى
ماليزيا وجدت ان هنا يعني سبحان ما زال
الاسلام بخير هنا وجدت اشياء يعني ربما لم
يجده
غيري
اول شيء من ناحيه
الحريه
الدينيه ماليزيا ما شاء الله دوله
يعني
تسامح يعني ترى كل اديان موجود يعني اسلام
البوذيه الهندي
الدين هنديه
يعني جميع نصرانيا ما في اي ضغط يعني يعني
ما ادري في اي دوله تستطيع ان تشوفه ما
شاء الله في شوارع في الطرق هناك مساجد
هناك يعني التماثيل لبوذي وهناك معابد
يعني فيه تسامح شيخ عجيب يعني هذه من
ناحيه دوله وان المسلمين
انا وجدت
المسلمين اول شيء الماليزيين ما شاء الله
مهتمين جدا جدا جدا جدا في
تربيه تعليم والتربيه اولادهم منذ صغرهم
للقران
القران
والاداب الاسلاميه
فلذلك تجد ما شاء الله هنا في ماليزيا
فوق الف
مدارس تحفيظ القران وهذه
المدارس كل ما شاء الله
توفر للاولاد كل شيء سكن
والاعاشه حتى هم ما شاء الله
التخرج كثيرا من حفاظ القران في ماليزيا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
والشمس
وضحاها
والقمر اذا
تلاها
والنهار اذا ج
ل
والليل
شاهى والس
ماء وما بناها
والارض وما
طحاها ونفس
سوا
وقد افلح
من
زكاها
وقد خاب
من
دساها
كذبت
ثمود بطغواها
[موسيقى]
بعث اشقاها
فقال لهم رسول الله
ناقه الله وسقي
اها
فكذبوا
فعقروها
تدمدم عليهم
ربهم
بذنبهم
فسواها
ولا
يخاف عقباها
طبعا ما شاء الله نحن كمسلمين الصينيين
يعني جاليان في ماليزيا وقبل الكورونا كان
عدد كبير جدا وهم يسكنون في هذه المنطقه
يعني متجمعين في اغلبهم في هذه المنطقه
فلذلك
عندنا الاخوه
بعد الاخوه بداوا
[موسيقى]
يفكرون ان ينشئ جماعه خاصه
للمسلمين صينيين الجاليات في ماليزيا لانه
اغلبهم لا يفهمون الخطبه الجمعه في المسجد
فالحمد لله يعني بعد
جهد
الاخوه
انشانا
الجماعه هذه
والحمد لله منذ
تقريبا سنتين نحن قد
صلينا رمضاننين في هنا
وما شاء الله حتى نحن نصلي صلاه الجمعه
هنا وصلاه العيد هنا وانا اذكر ما شاء
الله خاصه في رمضان
كان الجو جميل جميل جدا جدا ان كل يوم كل
يوم هنا
نحن
ندعو جميع
الصائمين والصائمات المسلمين المسلمات هنا
يفطرون افطار جماعي
وبعدها نصلي صلاه التراويح وفي اثناء
التراويح هناك الدرس
وبعد
التراويح كذلك هناك الدروس هناك مجالس
الذكر يعني ما شاء الله كان جو ايمانيه
جميله جدا جدا جدا وانا اذكر
الاخوه الذين
[موسيقى]
مكثوا في هذا البلاد
قديما قالوا نحن من كم سنه ما شفنا هذه
المنظر في ماليزيا
فهذا نعمه من الله
فكذلك
الان نحن
[موسيقى]
القران واللغه العربيه
لان العربيه هذه بالنسبه الينا اللغه يعني
نوعا ما مقدسه بالنسبه للمسلمين الصينيين
لان هي اللغه القران كيف نحن نقرا قران
ولا نفهمه فهذا بالنسبه الينا شيء لا يمكن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]